today at GDC a price and release window
has finally been revealed for
PlayStation VR sony has confirmed that
the headset will cost 399 dollars out of
the gate and it will release October
2016 this makes PlayStation VR one of
the cheaper headsets on the market by
comparison oculus rift goes on sale
later this month for six hundred dollars
while HTC vive arrives in April for
eight hundred dollars when major
difference or playstation vr however is
that it does not require a pc as it runs
on playstation 4 any of the 36 million
playstation 4 console is out there today
will be able to run the device during
the presentation playstation president
andrew house confirmed that there are
currently 230 developers working on
games for their vr headset PlayStation
VR headset uses a 5.7 inch 1080p OLED
display with 120 Hertz refresh rate and
18 milliseconds of latency and the
headset also supports
three-hundred-and-sixty-degree tracking
and we'll use the PlayStation Move
controllers and the dualshock 4
controller which headset are you leaning
towards the PlayStation VR the HTC vive
or the oculus rift let us know in the
comments below and for more on VR you're
already in the right place